[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a thai comedy youth drama
film called ugly ducklings series don't
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
may nom is an extremely shy and insecure
teenage girl who wears a box over her
head at all times she suffers from a
strange condition that causes her to
hate her own face she genuinely believes
that she is the ugliest person to exist
on the planet and has to be hidden from
people in fact she hasn't looked at
herself in the mirror for over three
years and has not stepped outside the
house either mae nom lives with her
brother plawan and her father mr bonn
who are always worried about her one
evening plowan returns home with a
bruised elbow and admits to shoplifting
to save himself from getting in trouble
he diverts his father's attention to his
sister being a total psycho because of
her condition mae naam also gets
frequent panic attacks and has
difficulty breathing when she is anxious
plouwon's comment hurts her making it
difficult for her to breathe mr bond who
has gotten used to her reactions over
the past years helps her calm down may
nam then narrates the story of her life
in her blog about how she became an ugly
duckling it may be surprising to people
that for the first 13 years of her life
maynam was like any normal person she
had friends a social life and was
confident about herself but then in
middle school she fell in love with the
most handsome boy in her class she was
so head over heels for him that one day
she confessed her love in front of
everyone however to her dismay the boy
did not reciprocate her feelings instead
he threw her gift to the ground and
called her the ugliest girl ever he even
asked her to wear a bag over her head
declaring her face to be a jump scare
all of her classmates followed the guy's
lead and called her ugly the incident
was so traumatizing for the poor girl
that she shut out from everyone around
her and refused to go to school again mr
bond tried his best to convince her
otherwise but upon realizing that she is
facing a real problem he let her get
homeschooled after the incident maynam
didn't look at herself in the mirror for
a year and didn't go outside at all that
is until one day she was outside the
house trying to retrieve a stuck balloon
a stranger approached and offered her
help maynam immediately put a paper bag
over her head to hide her face at that
moment she realized that the most
confident she feels is when her face is
covered the position of the bag felt
just right almost as if she had found
her soulmate and hence since that day
she has never shown her face to anyone
eventually the bag turned into a box
because it was more sturdy her family
gets a glimpse of her face sometimes but
menon prefers to stay hidden even from
them she hardly allows herself to look
into the mirror maynam enjoys most of
her time by anonymously talking to
people on social media she feels more in
place online since no one can see each
other's faces the next day mr bond goes
to her doctor and asks for an instant
cure for her sickness the doctor
clarifies that maynam is not sick she
has a strange condition famously known
as hikikomori in japan it mainly affects
adolescents or young adults who live
isolated from the world locked in their
bedroom for days months or even years
refusing to communicate with anyone
according to the doctor maynom's case is
not that serious because she still talks
to her family which means she has a
chance of socializing with other people
if she is forced to go out her only
problem is that she is scared the doctor
advises mr bond to get his daughter out
before she cuts off her family as well
at dinner maynam uses a straw to eat
refusing to take the box off in a heavy
voice mr bond asks his children to
listen to him carefully the siblings do
not let him talk and assume either he
has cancer or he is gay mr bond puts
down both claims and reveals that he
wants meinam to go to school with her
brothers starting tomorrow maynam thinks
he is joking and retaliates as he had
expected but this time mr bond doesn't
give in to her stubbornness and is
adamant about his decision even plawan
is surprised by his father's persistence
maynam declares that she hates him and
storms off to her room she cries for the
next hour nervous about tomorrow she is
certain that everyone will bully her for
the box still she prefers being bullied
to being called ugly to make her feel
better plouwon brings her a new box to
replace the old one and offers to help
her decorate it following that she takes
off the box for the first time and
reveals her face that is anything but
ugly plowan assures her that he won't
let people make fun of her but it
doesn't make her feel better then the
siblings decorate the new box for may
nom the following morning mr bond drives
his children to school while plowing
gets out of the car and walks in maynam
starts to hyperventilate under the box
mr bond plays calming music to help her
and motivates her to go in maynam
apologizes for saying mean thanks to him
last night and thanks him for trying to
help her as soon as she leaves mr bond
also breaks down crying worried for his
daughter minam holds her breath and
finally walks into the school the big
bright box on her head does not go
unnoticed everyone starts to point at
her and whisper which makes her panic
even more their laughs remind her of the
day she was humiliated all those years
ago maynam gets dizzy and is about to
pass out but a guy comes to help her
right on time he also has a helmet on
which makes her feel a bit better the
guy introduces himself as minton but she
gets nervous and runs away while she is
at it she accidentally bumps into the
school's most popular guy zero he and
his group of friends ask her to take the
box off curious about her looks when
maynam refuses to do so they surround
her and try forcing it off they are
stopped by minton who takes off his
helmet and reveals his face zero and
minton stare at each other in anger and
decide to solve the conflict outside
school minton then holds mainam's hand
and takes her away in the following
scene she is nervously standing in front
of the class the teacher has been told
about her condition so she requests the
students to respect her privacy but
being typical teenagers they start to
bully her urging her to show them her
face minton is also in the same class
and is angered by his classmate's
behavior maynam quietly walks to the
last seat and stays with her head down
most of the time during the lunch break
she goes to the cafeteria looking for
her brother but cannot find him anywhere
the students do not stop staring and
talking about her a pair of guys see her
eating with the box on her head and
force her to take it off everyone sees
them bullying her but laughs instead of
helping eventually maynam leaves her
food unfinished and runs outside crying
when she is alone in the playground
minton suddenly appears beside her he is
wearing a helmet which she thinks is to
mock her for her box minton clarifies
that he just likes the way he looks with
the helmet he then shares his sandwich
with her because she couldn't eat
earlier maynam feels a lot more
comfortable talking to him after that
they joke around and laugh but then she
says that she won't be coming to school
the next day minton declares that he is
her friend and urges her to come even if
it's only for him after school minton
and the bully zero meet as they had
promised they get into a verbal
altercation because of their differences
minton insults zero for always walking
around with his minions and challenges
him to a one-on-one fight zero takes it
and steps forward after asking his
friends to stay back minton lands the
first punch but zero fights back with an
equally powerful blow maynam is making
her way back home when she witnesses
them wrestling suddenly the police
arrive and the guys have to separate
zero sees her on his way out and pulls
her along with him after running off to
a quiet area he forces the box off her
head in a climactic scene he lays eyes
upon her face and is left speechless at
the sight but maynam thinks that he is
staring at her because she is ugly the
memories of her past trauma keep playing
in her head and she passes out when
mainam finally wakes up she finds
herself in the hospital bed without her
box she immediately starts to panic and
has to be given a face mask to calm down
her father is very sorry that he forced
her to go to school he blames himself
for getting her hospitalized and allows
her to stay home as she wanted to
everyone's surprise maynam declares that
she wants to return to school only
because she wants to take revenge on
zero for forcing her to take the box off
the following day zero is on his own
thinking about may nom he is confused as
to why she would cover up her face when
she is so beautiful just then maynam
arrives and slaps him in the face for
what he did yesterday when his minions
try to get close to her zero stops them
he yet again tries to take her face mask
off but is stopped by minton they get
into another fight because of her but
she stops them both and brings them
aside by now news about the two handsome
guys fighting for the box head girl has
circulated around the school maynam
yells at the guys for making her life
even more difficult when minton says he
only wanted to help her zero laughs he
is sure that minton is attracted to her
like he is minton also senses that zero
is trying to get with maynam and asks
him if it is true a flustered zero
denies it calling maynam ugly the
comment reminds her of her trauma and
makes her fall unconscious again minton
helps her while zero is left behind
jealous the next day maynam goes back to
her insecure phase she refuses to come
out of her room or talk to anyone mr
bonn and pluan are discussing what they
can do to help her when someone calls
them from outside their house zero has
come to apologize to mainam for his
mistake but plaun refuses to let him in
accusing him of sending maynam back to
the spiral of depression the next
morning minton comes to cheer her up but
she refuses to let him inside her room
upon his repeated requests she wears a
face mask and meets him to her surprise
he has made a duck box that she can use
to cover her face maynam cannot help but
burst out laughing at the site he has
also made a duck helmet for himself they
wear their respective head gear and go
to start a band called daft punk
actually they just eat together minton
promises to take care of her and
convinces her to come back to school the
next morning he drives her to school
with him when maynam is alone zero
approaches her and tries to apologize
but plawan disturbs them and sends him
away later during class a girl named
ozone approaches mae nom and asks her
for a favor it turns out that a rumor
about maynam and zero dating has been
circulating around the school since he
might listen to her ozone wants maynam
to stop him from bullying people maynam
denies having anything to do with him
and storms away even during the lunch
break a crowd of people ask her for
similar favors but she turns them all
down but then she is informed that zero
is beating up her brother on running to
check up on him she finds zero's friends
beating him to the ground zero makes
them stop and claims that plawan started
the fight a furious mainam calls him out
for being a thief who bullies weak
students for money and homework zero
looks at his minions in disbelief
because he had ordered them to never
bully someone weaker than them when mae
naam asks him to stop hurting people he
in turn urges her to take her box off if
she does so he promises to never use
violence for personal gain with no other
way to help everyone maynom takes the
box off and reveals her face everyone is
shocked at the sight later she hugs
minton crying that everyone saw her
today he is surprised to see her for the
first time but focuses on calming her
instead later at home plawan shows her
all the comments under a picture someone
posted of her although the comments are
positive it doesn't convince me nom that
she is beautiful then she enters her
room and sees the window as open zero
appears out of nowhere and asks her to
be quiet he apologizes for calling her
ugly and admits that she is in fact the
most beautiful girl he has ever seen
after he leaves his words keep on
repeating in meiwan's mind she asks her
internet friend to look at a picture of
her on the school's page when the friend
gushes about how cute she looks maynam
finally realizes that they must be
telling the truth for the first time in
more than three years she brings out a
mirror and discovers that she is
actually beautiful she almost does not
believe her eyes the following day
maynam goes to school without the box
all the students stare at her and gossip
but this time they are not making fun of
her but are rather admiring her beauty
although nervous maynam is ready to
start a new life with confidence she
never had before subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching